hello and welcome to the last agenda
before the summer break
we're here at the plenary in strasbourg
but let's take a look at what's
happening next week
at key committee meetings back in
brussels the criteria for opening a bank
account
varies and so do charges at the cost of
basic
bank services and especially
cross-border fees are particularly pesky
a new proposal on basic bank services is
the latest measure to regulate the
banking sector
by ensuring transparency of fees and
barring discrimination on the grounds of
nationality
residents and personal finances the
economic and monetary affairs committee
will consider the draft report on
tuesday
tobacco giants have lobbied and even
challenged it in court but a deal on the
tobacco products directive could be a
short whisper away
under the directive there would be a ban
on flavoured and slim cigarettes
and regulation of e-cigarettes is also
on the cards
but the biggest change is that 75 of all
packaging would have to carry a health
warning
the health committee will vote on the
draft report on wednesday
low-cost biofuels made from crops such
as rapeseed oil
are a great source of renewable energy
but studies show that they're actually
driving up food prices
and they generate more greenhouse gases
than they save
quiet in the back the eu now wants to
cap
crop-based biofuel production to 5 of
their 2020 renewable energy goals
could reduce production badly affect the
industry find out what mep's think when
the environment committee votes on the
draft report on thursday
and a quick mention of lithuania after
being passed the baton of the eu's
rotating council presidency from
ireland next week their ministers will
be busy attending committee meetings to
present
their programmes to meps
and that's all we have for this agenda
take care and enjoy the week